oh boy I I don't know I mean I'm
obviously looking forward to what's
going to happen in media and the way
that people consume a content that's
what I'm most interested in so clearly
the whole idea of mobile and the idea
that you're carrying around with you a
screen that can go with you and know
where you are and know who your friends
are utilizing that kind of technology to
immerse yourself into the world of a
narrative is something that I'm most
interested in how to create narrative
that that helps people understand what
their places in the world and how to
make the world a better place so those
kind of technologies are most
interesting to me
you know again right now I'm interested
I'm interested in as a storyteller in in
trying to use narrative to promote good
in the world so I'm interested in
companies that are that are
philanthropic by nature and are trying
to to promote the greater good so
technology that's designed to make the
world a better place is it's the most
interesting to me
you